Hello Karin
Haley
Byron
Daniel
Laura
This is the Nicholl Fellowship Comittee
You are a 2021 Nicholl Fellow
Hang on, can you say that again?
(laughter)
Wow, guys, thank you.
Okay, great. So, it's good.
It means you won.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god.
I am enormously happy.
What an accomplishment.
I really enjoyed
reading your scripts
You read it?
I loved your script.
I'm super psyched about that.
Let's just say you're the director.
It really comes down
to three things
hard work, luck and talent.
Thank you so much, truly.
Did that just happen?
That was so enjoyable
to explore the writing process.
It has felt all the way along
like a welcoming environment.
We all start somewhere.
It's helped me have
full confidence in myself.
I get to write every day.
There's nothing that can stop me
from doing that.
To get this sort of recognition
just made it all so worth it.